did you know that at least one saw
appears in each and every one of the saw
movies it's true sometimes they're used
for autopsies sometimes they're used for
severing body parts sometimes they're
just used for good old killing but the
namesake of the franchise has in every
installment at least
appeared once and sure you can find any
number of listicles online looking and
ranking the best saw films but have you
ever seen someone talk about the best
saws in saw no you have not so we ran
the numbers and get this the average
rotten tomato score for films where the
saw
doesn't kill someone is higher than the
movies where the saws do kill someone
34.6 versus 24.3 percent but appearances
of hacksaws
ultimately win the day movies with a
hacksaw average out to 33.75
movies with an electric saw like a buzz
saw or circular saw are much lower
at 23.5 percent looks like all the lists
are right friends
not all saws are created equal
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory a
show that
wants to play a game the rules of the
game you have 60 seconds to hit the
subscribe button or else uh
uh it can't really make you wear a
reverse bear trap or anything and uh
totally out of acid
if you don't subscribe you will have to
dress like cool kid jigsaw from the
final chapter
the only thing worse than death by saul
death by cringe
in 2004 millions of people went to the
theaters and saw the psychological
thriller saw
and everyone who saw saw knew it was
something special because it featured
brutal violence
interesting themes and a villain named
john jigsaw kramer who not only could
engineer brilliant traps but could lay
face first on a gross bathroom floor for
hours on end
to me the best thing about these movies
are the elaborate and creative traps
they present
a pit of needles a laser collar a
machine that slowly pulls your hair out
i mean they are
brutal contraptions after you hear those
iconic words
i want to play a game you know that
things are about to get serious well the
character on screen is forced to think
about survival on the fly the audience
is forced to ask itself largely the same
things like whether you'd actually be
able to use a hacksaw to take off your
foot you learn the rules of the game
with the characters and when one of them
miraculously survives it's thrilling
because you're in the situation with
them and you don't have to hear that
final tagline of
here's the thing though what if you
weren't safely in the audience as i've
talked about in a previous film theory
jigsaw's ideology is
wildly flawed thanks billy the puppet i
had to hack off my arm with a butcher's
knife because you didn't think i was
appreciating life enough but
man now i'm sure glad to be alive can't
wait for all those years of counseling
i'll be getting to deal with my
survivor's remorse
as such jigsaw's contestant selection is
a bit hard to predict in other words you
could very well be living a perfectly
upstanding life but potentially wind up
in the next reverse bear trap without
even knowing what you did wrong
and when that happens you can't go in
ill-prepared so that is our question for
today
how do you survive saw based on
everything that we see in the series is
nine movies what can you do to maximize
your odds of survival how do you not
just play the game but
hack the game in advance to give
yourself the best chance of living
possible
live or die make your choice
live live yep definitely choose and live
there
overall across the whole series there's
only 19 examples of when games are won
and 68 examples of when people
died that is a 21.8 percent success rate
which uh let's just say is not a grade
that's going to get you on to any honor
rolls
in other words the best first step to
surviving john cramer's game
is not getting selected in the first
place
so who does he pick and why well we took
john's own advice
if you're good at anticipating the human
mind it leaves nothing to chance
and analyzed every character game
timeline flashback motive and death to
help us avoid getting strapped into our
next shotgun carousel
jigsaw and his acolytes believe that the
death traps help people they attempt to
transform lazy or corrupt human beings
who devalue and squander their lives
into people with a refreshed
appreciation for their existence
and so yeah some of his victims make
sense in the first movie alone you have
people who've tried to take their own
lives people who commit fraud
drug addicts and adulterers but then
there are others like detective singh
who's a good cop
and was just killed by a shotgun trap in
jigsaw's lair or
zap a hospital orderly who's generally
very nice or alison and diana gordon two
family members that were kidnapped in
order to ensure that someone else who is
corrupt would play the game for a guy
that says
killing is distasteful
to me he casts a wide net one film in
and his choices are already pretty
questionable so after analyzing
all of the game contestants i came up
with a short list that tells you exactly
how to not be selected one don't be
corrupt or work for corrupt people it's
a pretty obvious one less obvious don't
be related or
married to anyone corrupt doesn't matter
if you appreciate life
as long as your relative or spouse
doesn't you're likely gonna be put into
the game it doesn't even matter if you
know about the corruption you're
in danger by association for instance in
saw two eric matthews son
is put in the game those who don't
appreciate life do not deserve
life my son appreciates his life but do
you appreciate yours
do you appreciate your sons oh this
unexpected corollary to all of this
don't be the spouse or child of someone
who's died because of a corrupt person
next up don't be a jerk no racists no
snitches no adulterers and don't you
dare laugh at the sick or elderly
because jigsaw is an aging sick man and
he does not take kindly to that getting
back into self-explanatory territory
don't do criminal activities like drugs
or murder and don't flee the scene of
your crime next one's a hard one try not
to be depressed i get it that might not
be in your control but if you are
depressed
hide it don't post publicly about it
seriously if you don't want to be locked
in a death furnace just keep your
melancholic tweets to yourself
don't oh here's a good catch-all
jobs avoid being a doctor or a cop
doesn't matter if you're good at your
job or bad jigsaw has taken people for
being both
too good and too bad pretty much all the
major law enforcement characters in this
franchise die
also you can be a janitor but only at
upstanding legal businesses if you're a
janitor at a corrupt business you are
fruit of the poisonous tree and will
likely be plucked
and working for big pharma or big
insurance is just right out
big no go there lastly and most
importantly do not pretend that you are
a survivor of jigsaw if you do
you your team everyone you love and care
about will die horribly it is not pretty
friends so that's the list
honestly i'd say you should just live in
a bubble and do nothing but then you
might be picked for a game because
you're hiding from the world and not
appreciating your life appropriately
good news though if you follow this list
you've severely lessened your chances of
being picked bad news is
you're still at risk
these guys are kind of fickle and
inconsistent let's say that one day
you're looking at your phone and you
bump into one of jigsaw's apprentices
spilling super hot coffee all over their
face this apprentice is now super
annoyed because the pig mask they wear
is gonna be super uncomfortable so
you're nabbed and put into a trap under
the excuse that you were absorbed in
your phone rather than looking up
appreciating the world around you
so congratulations you are now in a
jigsaw trap despite your best
efforts what do you do well when you
break it down statistically there are
seven different types of traps in
jigsaw's games standard traps
competitions
tests trials security traps execution
traps and inescapable traps standard
traps are devices or scenarios applied
to a victim that will kill the test
subject if the task isn't completed
within a certain amount of time the
iconic reverse bear trap is a classic
example as is sawtoo's death mask
and saw four's knife chair competition
traps involve two or more victims that
can pass their tests individually but
only at the expense of the other victim
saw 3d's love triangle where two
boyfriends and the cheating girlfriend
between them have to decide who gets
sawed to death is pretty iconic for this
tests are games that involve a victim
being given instructions to a specific
task like zep having to kidnap an
innocent family in the first movie in
order to live
trials are a series of tests that the
victim has to face in order to show
psychological progress this is basically
every puzzle seen throughout saw
five a security trap is just a glorified
security device like the quadruple
shotgun hallway trap which is literally
just a bunch of guns on a tripwire
execution traps are just there to finish
off people in creative ways like soft
five's water cube
where there's no game there's just death
and lastly there are the
inescapable traps which as the name
implies are just used to kill people
like the rigged pendulum trap
sure there's a game that you can play to
quote unquote win but the game is rigged
against you regardless of what you
actually do
so equipped with all that information
what do you do well the number one rule
in all of the saw franchise is that
rules of our game have been made very
clear
you need to abide by those rules i
understand that it's easier said than
done when it comes to listening to a
tricycle riding puppet giving you
instructions and you have like 60
seconds on the clock but jigsaw
is pretty upfront about how to play and
win each game
research shows that fear can actually
cause your brain's executive network
which is responsible for problem solving
to constrict and work less effectively
which means that you're gonna have to be
prepared to listen
intently when each game begins saw two
is full of people screwing this
fundamental lesson up in saw two a note
explicitly says do not attempt to use
this key on the door to the room the key
is used to open the door
and booby kills someone later all
detective eric matthews had to do was
sit around
in order to win i want to play a game
the rules are simple
all you have to do is sit here and talk
to me listen to me you can do that long
enough then you will find your son
in a safe and secure state instead he
falls victim to jigsaw's tricks and
winds up in multiple movies and a long
series of traps trying to escape until
eventually dying in saw four
it also doesn't help that only 31.25
of entrants in the standard traps
actually pass what's even worse than
that is that three of the games were
rigged two of the five people who passed
their tests were killed immediately
afterward and all
five of them ended up dead later on in
the series surviving a game doesn't
always mean that you're gonna be alive
later which means that we need to go on
to lesson number two
just go ham on it if you have a chance
of winning you need to go
hard and you need to go fast we see this
with amanda in saw two's pit of needles
and more so with
charles in soft five's necktie trap by
acting fast and first in his group he's
able to ensure his survival
while everyone else is still left in
danger and with that good news
you've passed the isolated test and your
hands are probably crushed if not
entirely sawed off as you walk away you
hear
jigsaw saying congratulations you are
still alive most people are so
ungrateful to be alive but not you not
anymore
you respond with a hearty thumbs up if
your bleeding hands can still manage to
move and you pretend to walk away with a
swagger that indicates that you are
very grateful to be alive the bad news
is that as you approach the exit a man
in a pig mask
drugs you heals your hands and then
locks you up in yet another room this
time with total strangers billy pops
back up again and tells you that
everyone needs to work together to pass
a series of competition traps and trials
and you have three hours to do so
because you have poison flowing through
your veins that'll melt you from the
inside out i hate to tell you this
but only 13 of the 41 games or 25.4
percent of jigsaw's tests that involve
two or more people are passed in games
that have four or more people working
together the odds are definitely stacked
against you
only four of the 17 people in the four
plus group games walked out alive and
even those numbers lie considering two
of those are coming from saw two with
one being a jigsaw apprentice
placed in the game to keep the other
survivor safe tldr here the odds are
stacked against you but you can increase
your odds by killing and sacrificing all
your teammates now that might sound like
i'm a horrible person but don't blame me
blame the game maker and also the
numbers statistically
the group will turn on you eventually
considering that we see it happen in saw
soft 5 and jigsaw psychologically
speaking everyone deals with trauma
differently now add in a ticking clock
and the threat of poison killing you and
you have a recipe for disaster
the people in your group will develop
tunnel vision they'll become hysterical
they'll develop a fight-or-flight
reaction which hinders your chances at
survival and these challenges are
already hard enough the last thing you
need is other people weighing you down
in a crisis moment so
just deal with them early before you're
forced to deal with them as an added
bonus make sure you bring a dead body or
two with you to the next room their
flesh
blood insert vital organ here is
probably going to be helpful in the
upcoming trial
and speaking of bringing stuff with you
remember what tools you really have
available and bring as much with you
between chambers as you can
in most of jigsaw's challenges
especially the trials you are the one
progressing things forward
shutting doors behind you etc to start
timers so before you lock yourself
into the next game make sure that you're
going in prepared assess the scene
take your time go back to the room that
you just left and pick up things that
might be helpful
any tools broken pipes long sticks your
fellow deceased contestants remember
that in pretty much all
circumstances jigsaw is letting you keep
your clothes on and things like jackets
belts shoes can do a lot in these sorts
of situations
between your tools and clothes and the
tools and clothes that might be coming
from your deceased contestants you can
actually do a lot
here most of these traps work remotely
and use fairly rudimentary tools to
operate
pressure plates simple chains and
hydraulics so having a bit more reach
and the ability to shove something hard
and solid into contraptions can actually
help a lot
lastly urine can act as a substitute for
blood assuming it didn't all leak out
due to fear in the first chamber and
with that you walk out of your final
test
congratulations you've survived now
relax in the knowledge that you'll be
surveilled by jigsaw and his crew for
the rest of your life cause that's
exactly what happens to most of the
survivors in these movies so keep your
head low
research any companies that you plan on
working for listen follow the rules
sacrifice anyone and everyone around you
and then pretend to be happy that you
went through the single most frightening
experience in your life
seize the day jeff for real go running
naked in a hail storm kiss a girl in the
middle of the day fly a kite but do it
for yourself
well yourself and the pig masked army
watching your every move waiting for any
excuse to throw you back into another
game
but hey that's just a theory this
however could be the beginning of a long
summer of the best horror movie
franchises out there
i love horror movies all year round
actually just finished re-watching all
the conjuring movies in honor of the new
one releasing and if you're looking to
beat the heat this summer
consider getting your chills from
today's sponsor shutter
i use shutter to help with horror movie
research for this channel and
statistically
horror is a genre that you the audience
of this channel love it's why we do
horror movie episodes like this one
because you guys watch the heck out of
him which means that you are going to
watch the heck out of shudder shutter is
the place to go to to brush up on
everything from your horror movie
classics like braum stoker's dracula and
halloween or dive deeper into the genres
that really get to you
they currently have streaming the
scariest movie i've ever seen in my life
audition they also have heather's which
is like 90
comedy and like 10 horror and made an
amazing musical years later the long and
short of it is that no matter what
you're looking for in the category of
scares it is there
including exclusives like the reckoning
and their original creep show which is a
horror anthology a la american horror
story another one of my favorites
to try shutter for free for 30 days go
to shutter.com and use the promo code
film theory that's
s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com not shutters like the
things on the outside of your house with
that 30 days free you can watch horror
movies every night of the week at your
barbecue at your pool party in the
showers at the beach the possibilities
are endless as are the jump scares check
it out in the description below and as
always thank you for
supporting the sponsors who support us
because it means that they will continue
to support us
in the future which is great you get
cool content we get funding to do more
episodes like this it's a win-win-win
for everyone involved so in the meantime
remember it
is just a theory a film theory and
cut